according to ITV the broadcaster of the
Grand National the national broadcaster
who has announced in the past few
minutes there is going to be an
indefinite delay to the start of the
Grand National you can see it on your
screen there amid a number of
protests that we know don't we that
animal rights activists had threatened
to cause disruption we know that three
people were arrested during the course
of the day on suspicion of conspiracy to
cause a public nuisance that is ahead of
the main race first of all we knew that
a 33 year old woman from London was
arrested in the greater Manchester area
earlier in the day and then two people
had subsequently been arrested very
close to the course 55 year old man were
told from greater Manchester and a 25
year old woman and that woman who was 25
believed to be Claudia Pena Rojas one of
the organizers of this demonstration who
actually appeared on news a little
earlier this morning she had said we
will be slow marching around the
perimeter and at some point we may
peacefully try to make our way towards
the track to stop the race from
happening so that is the latest it was
due to begin at quarter past five to
just four minutes away the main race at
the Grand National one of the most
eagerly anticipated
races of the calendar it's not happening
well not happening for now an indefinite
delay